23 heures passées dans ce restaurant de
la capitale russe les derniers clients
sont raccompagnés par la police
fermeture des restaurants et bars entre
23 heures et 6 heures du matin
annulation des événements réunissant
plus de 1000 spectateurs
depuis ce vendredi les autorités ont
réintroduit des mesures pour lutter
contre une flambée record du nombre
d'infections kovy 19 causés par le
variant delta représentant près de 90%
des malades
il était donc 500 au lieu des 1500 prévu
lors du congrès du parti russie unie de
vladimir poutine ce samedi un congrès au
cours duquel le président russe a appelé
une nouvelle fois ses concitoyens à se
faire vacciner les conséquences de la
maladie causée par l'infection de covit
font toujours l'objet des recherches
il ne s'agit pas seulement de lésions
pulmonaires mais aussi de lésions
vasculaires
les spécialistes ont encore à clarifier
où cela mène je vous rappelle encore une
fois que se faire vacciner c'est mieux
qu'être malade
il s'agit de la position des principaux
experts dans notre pays et dans le monde
entier
il faut dire que la campagne de
vaccination dans le pays a du mal à
décoller avec à peine plus de 10% de la
population ayant reçu les deux doses du
vaccin spoutnik v un retard non pas en
raison d'un manque de doses mais plutôt
d'une certaine méfiance de la population
le taux ni nos gens ont une mentalité
telle qu'ils ne veulent pas faire ce
qu'ils sont obligés de faire je ne sais
pas quoi faire pour les vacciner
il faudrait être vaccinés auprès de sa
mère
face à la situation la vaccination est
devenu obligatoire pour une partie de la
population moscovite sous peine d'amendé
les entreprises vont devoir s'assurer
qu'au moins 60% de leurs salariés ont
bien reçu deux doses du vaccin au 15
août prochain sont concernés les
secteurs d'activités de l'éducation du
transport du commerce de la restauration
de la santé ou encore les employés
municipaux les fonctionnaires soit au
total deux millions de personnes je
pense que nous n'avons pas besoin d'une
vaccination obligatoire
nous devrions avoir la liberté de choix
dans tous les cas chacun le droit de
décider
de plus le vaccin n'est pas testé sur le
long terme 10 15 ou 20 ans ne ne sont
pas encore écoulées et nous ne savons
pas quelles sont les conséquences pour
les gens le gouvernement russe s'était
fixé l'objectif d'atteindre l'immunité
collective d'ici la fin de l'été
un objectif qui paraît aujourd'hui
ambitieux alors que vladimir poutine a
annoncé ce samedi le lancement d'un
programme de plus d'un milliard d'euros
pour renforcer le système de santé du
pays